Você já se perguntou por que você
continua sentindo-se cansado ou Cansada
mesmo após se recuperar de uma gripe ou
outra infecção viral a síndrome pós
viral acontece quando você tem fadiga e
outros sintomas após uma infecção por
vírus como a gripe por exemplo a fadiga
aparece porque combater uma infecção
requer energia e recursos seu sistema de
defesa imune podendo diminuir e esgotar
alguns nutrientes importantes também a
infecção viral pode causar inflamação e
Danos oxidativos que podem afetar a sua
função cerebral e muscular essa condição
é parecida com uma deficiência de
vitaminas B1 e B3 que também causa
fadiga e problemas cognitivos a
deficiência de B1 que é a tiamina pode
causar fadiga em pessoas com alergias
doenças causadas por fungos ou mofo
infecções crônicas por vírus e problemas
digestivos